好 那接下来我讲
这个
在今年7月中一天输200多万的交易实战复盘
那那个时候
就是我最近每年都会去
拉斯维加斯赌博个一两个月左右的去玩一下
在就是我没有特别
算好
就是
坐飞机的时间
那我应该之后会
稍微考虑一下
就是坐飞机的时间应该要避免
避开一些事件
那当时我
这个飞回来的时间那天刚好会是台积电的法说会
那法说会就有
一个法说会的策略
那在
在那个法说会之前呢
就是
股市就是已经
前面是法说会前嘛
然后
这边是
这边是这个台积电的夜盘开盘
就是5.25的时候
然后这边是3点
就是
这边是法说会的过程
然后就是
往上跳空了一段
这样
好反正呢
就是前面的法说会策略
因为我在坐飞机就没有打
就没有打到
但是呢我在飞机上是有用WiFi的
所以呢我就是看到
这个
就是
学我策略的大家呢
就赚了很多钱
然后我就觉得说
我也想要打到
所以在后面的这个
台积电的
夜盘开盘的时候
我也想要参与
就是
在飞机上打单
那当然呢
我们事后来看呢
在飞机上打单当然是非常不好的
因为在
我前面
可能
你看我以前的群艺演讲
其实
后
后面
接下来我要讲的都讲过很多次了
就是
这个
情绪管理制度
还有这个
就是
就是交易的
科学化的
的那个控制情绪的制度
里面都有讲说
就是不要用手机下单啊
一定要只能在用电脑下单
而且一定是
就是在你家的
电脑上面下单
因为这样网络速度才是够快
而且你确定他的设置都是很正确
然后不要在
什么
就是
之前我还有学生在什么高铁上打单
然后他
可能交易一个什么失业率的公布
然后他按下去之后呢
过了一分钟那个单才成交
还有成交在100点外
就是
确实
就是连我也会犯这样的错误
就是你看到别人赚钱
你就是觉得说
虽然我在搭飞机
但我还是很想要参与
那
就是在
就是非常不好
好
那所以
结果我在
这边
这个台积电的这个下单
下单之后呢
没想到他就一直跌一直跌
那因为这个来飞机上操作总是都是非常非常缓慢的
然后
而且
就是
你按了之后
你也没有办法
很轻易的马上
设定出价停损
然后所以
就是那次的台积电他的法说会公布是
就是数据是超级超级好
结果没想到在
这个
台积电夜盘开出来之后反而是一个大暴跌
那所以我就直接吃到了
因为没有设那个自动的出价停损
就直接吃到很大的一段伤害
然后就直接一天输了两百多万
这个是
我去年
这个
一天输非常非常多的时候
然后那一次
不过那一次
就是下飞机之后我反而是觉得这件事情其实非常的有趣
然后就把那个
写了一个FB
发出来这样子
好
那
就是
我下面要讲的是
怎么用科学化的方式去
控制我们的
这个
交易中的下注尺度
那
这个是
我在每一次讲座下半场几乎都会讲
因为
其实好像
很少的交易者是
就是比较懂一些行为经济学
然后科学就是
科学化的
在描述交易心理这件事情
就是大部分人就是讲说
这个我们这个
交易最难的是心理
然后我们
要控制赔
这个
要战胜我们的心魔
交易最难的是心
但是
其实
就是这个里面蕴含很多错误嘛
就是大部分人赚不到钱
其实是因为他不会数学
那
你的策略本身就是付EV的
你当然做交易本来就不会赚钱嘛
就是
那个
心理其实只是你能不能够
表现
执行出你原本要执行的那件事情
那
只是你在看
这个NBA
访问他们说
这个你
说最后这个
冠军战
那
你们觉得
关键是什么
那可能他会说
我觉得最关键的是
你能不能发挥出你平常训练的表现
那
就是
他当然不会说什么
最关键的是你
会不会在运球的过程中
然后球就掉了
对吧
就是这个不是他们顶尖的选手会关注的事情嘛
那所以你可能会常常听到
访问顶尖高手的时候他会说最重困难的是那个
心理能不能表现出来但是
其实最重要还是
你原本做的事情是不是对的
好那另外就是
就是说什么
啊
这个
最难的是心啊
这个心魔最难
这个
基本上就是跟你问说考试有什么技巧
然后你跟他说
会的题目都要写对
不要初心
就是跟废话一样
说要怎么样不初心
不要初心就是
你会的题目尽量要
多检查
就是要写对
就是你没讲到
具体要怎么样执行嘛
对不对
但是在这个
科学化情绪管理资助里面的话
就是
我
就是让大家知道要怎么样
科学化的
具体的可以执行的
决定的交易的下注尺度
然后要怎么样的调整
然后还有
就是我们不可避免的
就是在
交易的过程中一定会有
玩到生气
就是
英文叫onteurte的时候
变形的时候
那你要怎么样子去控制这样的情绪
然后并且停止这样的事情
好
那所以
这个科学化情绪管理资助就是
本于科学事实
然后他要是
这个具体明确可以执行
好这个是
蛮重要的
因为大部分人讲
这个交易心理的时候
他们都没有讲出具体明确可以执行的方法
只跟大家说
对
考试不要初心很重要
那这就跟没讲一样
好那第1个是我们要讲
我们要寻找自己的精神利等级
那精神利等级就是
就是
你可以
能够正确执行
你的下单策略的
最大下注尺度
然后他不能
超过凯利公司的建议
但是大部分人本来就不会超过
好那就是
简单来说就是你要尽量的
下注越大越好
但是
又不能
还到升期
那如果你每次都只下注一块钱的话
那当然很容易正确的执行
但是
你每次都
只下注一块台币
那当然就赚不到钱
但是如果你每一笔
下注都下注你总资产的30%
那你可能很容易不遵守GPD
说你赔掉30%之后你就觉得说
干嘛赔掉30%
很多钱
这样真的生气到不行
你就很想要在随便的
就是靠运气下单把它赚回来
那这样的话
就是非常非常不好的
也就是说我们不能下太多
也不能下太少
那我们要怎么样找到
我们尽量下很多但是不会玩到生气的
下注尺度呢
好就是我们尽量不能玩到until
那就是
就是
你的精神力就是找到你自己能
情绪不失控的最大下注尺度
这就是认识自己
好反正就是我们需要
认识这个世界然后认识自己
这样你才可以把各
各样的事情做好
那这也
不只是在交易里面
只是在各式各样的事情里面
都是一样
认识世界认识自己
好那升降级制度就是
我们所有人都
一开始都是预设自己是最低的
下注尺度
然后再慢慢往上升
那这样的好处就是
这样的话就非常的保守跟安全
就是
你
你都从
最小那台直期的话就是
我建议从
一小台可以不用去下围台
因为围台他的
手续费占比实在是太高了
所以就是
可以从一小台开始升级
那如果可以稳定执行获利的话就升级加大你的下注尺度
那如果你
会玩到升级或者是
你会太紧张没有办法按得很正确的话
那你就降级缩小你的下注尺度
好
那
确保能够正确执行
就不只是
精神层面
也包含
设备啊网路啊
环境啊
就是
或许你的
这个下单系统
会有什么样的问题
或者是说呢
其实你
不是很会算那个保证金
有时候
你算错了你以为你可以按
结果你按5下去之后
你保证金其实不够
或是你不了解那个挂单的规则
就是每个券商可能他挂单规则不一样
有的挂
挂单他就会直接把你扣额度
那个就是你的保证金额度就会被消耗掉
所以你如果在很远的地方已经挂了你的保证金可能已经被消耗掉
那有的
有的话是
不扣
你可以
直接
狂暴的挂一大堆
那反正最下面的执行
执行到上面
他不能执行的才退单
那这变成是跟
券商的
游戏规则有关
所以就是在你在升级的过程中
就不只是
能不能够正确执行策略就不只是
你的情绪能不能够
控制住还有包含
一些设备网络环境下单系统也都
可能会随着你的下注尺度提高而没有办法正确的执行
那或者是你下注口述增加可能
这个在快市就是
失业率啊
CPI啊
然后
这个
每年除利率公布这些
就是
这个价格会超级快速跳动的时候
那可能你原本
都是只下一口的
那
你就不会有滑架太远的问题
那但是呢
你在下注可能
五口十口的时候
那你就会
开始面临到你的网户速度不够好
那所以
就是直接滑架滑到超暴远的这样的情况
好
那所以就是这些都是这个
决定下注尺度的方法的
情绪管理制度需要保护的事情
就是
就是不只是精神层面还有其他的层面
好
就是
升降级制度保护的层面很
很
很广泛
好反正呢就是尽量
我们都是用非常保守的方式在做交易
好那这个台子期他就可以有你自己的等级嘛
那
最新手就是你连这个尾买尾卖它是
怎么样挂单然后你都不太知道
的话
你可以
先按一按模拟单
然后之后呢
你就可以从
一小台开始
那我是建议不要下
微台
就是刚刚说的他
他手续费
占比实在是太大
所以
就是
就是那个会你会直接被庄家抽水给抽爆
所以就是尽量不要下微台
然后
在后来你
每次
可以在那个level可以稳定的
正确的执行的策略的话
我建议每一次就是
升级到两倍左右
就是一小台变两小台
变一大台
两大台
这样
然后再
变成两大台之后呢
可以升级慢一点
就是
每次又加一大台
加一大台
这样好
因为
大部分人的
普通人啊
就是精神力等级
大概就是在
四到五大台的地方
就是
四到五大台的话大概是
台指
指数只跳动一点
就会是
800块到1000块
那因为
大部分人的感受
会很容易把那个你的输赢
跟你自己
工作一天
或者是工作一个小时的
时薪做
对标
你会感受说
这个是我工作几天赚的钱
那如果
那个指数跳动一点
大概就
就快要是你
一个小时
甚至一个小时都赚不到的钱
的话
那个感受就是会
压力就会开始比较大
好所以大部分人
就是
的精神力大概就是
四到五等
好所以就是前面每次都翻倍
然后到四到五
到两等之后可以
慢慢的每次加一点
然后但是呢
尽量不要大小台混合的下
因为
就是
你变成是要下两个下滥甲
你出错的机会就会
大幅的上升
而且
小台的手续费占比还是比
大台高很多
所以尽量
能够
升级到只下大台
就不会再去下小台
好
然后再来就是
这个
如果
打到一次on tier的话
就可以降超过一级
例如说
你打到
五大台的时候
发现
你有一次玩到很生气
然后就乱按
那你可能可以把你自己降回
一大台之类的
因为
或许你的精神力是
下两到三大台的时候
你还不会到很生气
只是你下两大台的时候
刚好没有遇到
输钱的情况
因为通常是输钱的情况
才会玩到很生气
那你可能
这两大台的时候没有遇到一天输很多的情况
你就再升级到三四五
玩到五大台的时候才
出现一次输很多你很生气的情况
那
你玩到很on
你可以一次
降多一点
因为你的精神力只是
在这个里面的
不知道哪个地方
那你一次降多一点
再重新慢慢升上来
这样也会是比较安全保守的做法
那这个就是
最后大家都可以
免费得到这些
PPT
只是
就是把文字的列出来
这样的话
比较
反正大家就是
可以
就是也不需要
那个
抄写
或者是一定要看影片
反正大家都会有
PowerPoint
好然后
有什么吗
好
再来就是升级要很慢
不要
尽量不要有on的情况
但是呢
因为我们
尽量要在精神力等级的附近
下单嘛
所以呢
我们一定会
就是生涯会遇到很多次
打到on的情况
因为如果没有的话
那就是
你一直以来都下注太小了
因为你是在
你可能会
打到on的
的那个等级之下
来打嘛
但是其实你的
情绪控制能力
不会每天都是一样的嘛
或许你最近的
心情比较差
或者是最近
就是比较生气还是怎样的
那
只是有可能
是比较容易on的
好所以就是
我们尽量避免
但是呢
我们要知道
打到on
是
一定会出现
而且你也必须要它出现的情况
因为如果都没有的话
就是下注都太小
好然后
好这个刚刚也讲过
刚刚有讲过就是
你无论怎么升级
你升级都不能够超过凯利公司的建议
那凯利公司就是
就是你要
下注
你的停损要是现有
资金的
的多少
或者是如果它是一个
输了会
赔掉
某一个金额的话
那
就是你赚
可以赚多少
要输输多少的话
你要
可以接受输多少
然后
这个
B是
就是你赢跟输的赔率
就是
赢跟输
赢可以赢几倍
然后例如说赢可以赢200块
输好会输100块
那赔率就是2
然后P是获胜的几率
然后
这个
Q是落败的几率
大概
好那因为只有
如果只有赢跟输的
情况的话
就会是1-P
那有一些
游戏
不是直接0
跟1
就是不一定只有两种情况
例如说选择权就不是
那可能
可以用不一样的数据模型
不过
基本上简单来说呢
就是
你的胜率越高
获胜机会越大
然后或者是
你
赚跟赔的比例
越大的话
那你就应该要下注
越大的金额
然后那个
因而会是有一个上限的
那在
这
就是按着凯利公式来下注的话
就是
他的
这个
对数上涨
就是划成对数图表的上涨
的速度是最快的
也就是说你资产
持续翻倍的速度是最快的
这样
好
那但是呢
凯利公式推荐的下注尺度
对人类来说
一般
就太大了
就是他
财利公式是找
这个最大化对数期望值的下注比例
那但是
就是
他的中间可能会非常的跌宕起伏
例如说
你在
这个赚了30%之后呢
可能会赔掉80%的本金
然后又在
这个
再赚回200倍的钱之类
就是
他会是一个跌宕起伏的过程
那这个不是
人类
可以轻易接受的
而且他很容易引发你会玩到肮嘛
你可能会情绪失控
会去乱下单
然后如果你把
这个你玩到
这个很昂
昂theter
来
所以因此输更多钱
也考虑进去的话
那或许你下单下这么大
反而长期来说是不赚钱的
因为你玩到嗡的时候会
会输更多钱嘛
所以人类会希望资产
波动的
这个
捉荡要小一点
然后情绪要可以接受
好
那就是我们
举一个例子嘛
就是例如说
因为这个
如果是
短停损长停利的策略
胜率大部分
会低于
50%
然后但是会有一个
不错的赔率
那在我前面影片
以前我也讲过很多次吧
就是尽量我们
嗯
好
那就是
就是
如果我们要是一个正期望值的策略
大部分情况
你要设一个短停损长停利的策略
会是比较好的
因为
这个平均来说趋势还是比较容易有延续的
无论是什么样的原因
例如说这是一家很赚钱的公司
或者是
AI正在蓬勃的发展
或各式各样这些原因都会
导致
这个
上涨比较容易继续一直上涨
下跌比较容易继续下跌
那所以
这个
一般性的描述来说的话
短停损长停利会是比较好的
那所以
那因为短停损长停利可能停损是10
那
停利是30
这样的话
胜率低于50%
是
是蛮不错的
也是很正常
那
例如说若有一个40%的获胜几率然后
但是
这个
赚赔比是一赔五的
赌局
那这个是一个非常非常好的赌局嘛
是超级好好的不行
那但是我们就
应该每一次中下注
现有资金的25%如果它是只有赢跟归零的话
那
它
就是最大化资金的长期增长率
例如说
你可以
被允许的是
每天有一次的下单机会
那这样的话
这个
你的
资金
翻倍的那个LOG的速度会是最快
好
但是呢
也就是说如果你有1000万的总资金的话
依照凯仪公司你每一次
的
可以接受的损失会是25%
也说
一次就是损失
250万
那在
下一次第2次停损
因为你的钱变少
便只剩750万
所以下一次
会变少嘛
就是变成
这个再输185万
也就是说呢
这个如果是一天一次的下注机会的话
你在两天之后就会输掉
这个437万
那
大概会
因为他是一个40%的胜率嘛
所以大概会有36%大约1/3的机会
这个会在第2天的时候从1000万输到只剩562万
然后大概会有1/5就是20%的机会
连续停损三次的话是从
1000万输到剩421万
那
这个是人类的情绪比较无法接受的分支情况
就是
你正在执行了一个
超级高期望值
然后
超级好的下单机会
可是呢
你的
可能原本总资产是1000万
下了两天之后变剩560万
输了400万
在下一天变成
输了
输到不到
剩不到一半就是
就是20%其实还是
蛮容易发生嘛
就是它也不是一个很罕见的情况
对吧
就是20%
就是很常发生的情况
那
人类可能1000万
输500多万变400万
他可能就会很生气
他就会开始乱下单
乱
乱搞之类的
那这个是
人类无法接受的分支情况
所以呢大部分人的
精神力就是
没有到达凯利公式这么高
如果是升降级制度的话
你可能就是
先一次先下个
可能5万
然后10万20万
你慢慢的提升你自己的精神力
那
就是当然这样的话你的资产
就不会以最快的速度对数的上涨嘛
但是
就是
就是你会比较容易
长期稳定的执行这样的策略
毕竟
就是
如果你
游戏过程中
过程中会ontill的
机会也算进去的话
那可能会
就是
一次扣太多的期望
好
那所以凯利公式是升降级制度的上限
超过
则反而数学上会更差好
就是例如说
虽然他是一个很棒的下注机会
但如果你每次都下注
50%的总资产
那反而
你资产
这个增加的
这个
就是期望值的对数反而是没有那么好
那
如果你每次都是
下注100%的总资产
的话
那就会非常不好
就是在大部分的情况里你的资产都是会归零
好
所以就是
并不是说
期望值
是正的的策略
那就下注越高越好
那他是会有一个数学上的
上限是
是最好的
那就是这个海力公式
好
那不过呢大部分人其实也不太会下超过
大部分人精神力没有那么高
大概这样说才对
你un test的时候可能就会下超过
好
那这个我们刚刚有讲嘛
就是
这个以我
交过很多人
或者是
这个
就是
意义
因为这个当然是只说台湾嘛
就是
台湾是
整个地球上非常非常有钱的一个地方
对吧
我们大家都
有这个
充足的
这个
食物啊
这个WiFi啊
然后有电子产品可以使用
然后我们
就是反正在地球上我们是非常非常有钱的
当然
在其他国家的精神力可能不一样嘛
例如说美国他们的
这个平均收入
就是
就算端盘子一个月也有十几万台币
那他的
精神力可能就平均会更高
那对他们来说我们就是窮困的国家
这一点点的钱就是
会
心理有很多
那但是
可能在其他国家就是不一样
好
好反正就是在台湾
这个
普通中产阶级
就是有在投资的人大概
应该会是中产阶级
附近嘛
大概
比较常见会在四到五等的精神力
所以也不用
说什么
这个
我怎么精神力只有五等
然后
就是
你看那个投资大臣一次都按五十口三十口
但是
其实就是
我们就是认识世界认识自己嘛
你的精神力是五
那你就每次都按五就好了
不一定要
就是就算你有
就是三栋房子的时候
你可能精神力还是五
因为你是一个上班族
你就是认为
你平常上班
一个小时
可能就是
赚
可能平均一个小时就是五百块
那你的精神力就维持在这边
其实也没有什么不好的
好
然后我自己也没有办法依照凯一公司的最优数
数学尺度来下注
因为那需要很高的精神力
那
我自己也没有办法很好的执行
那但是也没有关系
而且
我也会尽量感受我的
这个精神力有什么样的变化
例如说
我反而在
这个
以前可以
就是下注二十左右
二十大台左右
但是我最近大部分都是下五大台或十大台
就是你还是可以感受一下你自己
的这个情绪啊
或者是
就是
你遇到的事情
让你的情绪的变化
那你可能
那你的下注尺度会
会有点不一样
好
然后
认识世界认识自己这个是
这个
就是
我以前也当过五台剧演员
认识自己是
是
了解自己
几乎你做任何事情都应该要先能够
做到的
那
然后这也是非常困难非常重要但是
很少人
去尽量做到的
好然后
认识自己之后才可以比较好的认识这个世界
就是大部分人
很容易
会
认为
就是
你去同理别人的时候会觉得说
那别人的想法就是要跟自己一样
就是说
好我很喜欢
吃甜不辣那怎么会有人不喜欢吃甜不辣呢
对吧
就是其实大部分人很容易有类似这样的想法
好
就是
就是提升同理心还是
需要跟
这个同时
越来越剥削多的关系
然后接受自己有精神力的上限
好那后面这个是
就是
跟上一次一样的
的PowerPoint
就是
徒弟比
师傅的精神力高好几倍也没有关系
例如说
我有一个
胡弟然后他的精神力是比我高非常非常多
然后他是一个
大学生也比我年轻很多
但是他可以下单
非常非常大
他也是
是就是
可以很
正确的执行而且很淡然的
看这些事情
那如果依照凯利公司的建议下单会怎样呢
那大家可以想象吗
如果一个人一直
按照凯利公司
下单会怎样
就是
会赚很多钱
对吧
因为他是以
资金会以数学上最快的速度翻倍
那所以
就是有一个精神力很高的学生
他是大学生
然后他是期货的完全新手
然后完全依照
数学上的最优质型
然后使用凯利公司建议的最高杠杆
然后获利也都
再次的投入他的资金以继续升级
而且他也没有
就是长线的持单完全都是
做
就是这些事件交易
就是毕竟
我是
做这些事件交易为主
因为事件交易比较容易
会是这些
低风险高报酬的
交易机会
然后
就是
那他在800万本金然后在三个月之后就赚了
460万
就是
三个月就
加58%赢了400多万这样子
然后
就是他是完全什么都不会的
纯新手开始学
然后在
在前面一开始的时候他的
那个
手续费还是在
一大台50
就是他都还没有跟
营业员
去
打电话说要改他手续费然后在
这个
就是
下单了几天之后他的手续费才降低到
35其实还是蛮高的
像我是28
就是
应该说如果他交易量这么大的话
35才是很高
我说
平常人的话
如果
如果营业员愿意给你35
就是
就是已经是很正常的
对
毕竟我们在期货商讲
还是要尽量帮期货商讲话一下
好就是
如果你拿到40
或到35之间
但你交易量没有很大的话
都
都还是
非常非常正常合理的
那
就是
反正他在某个时间之后他才
他下了三天之后他
他才
变成
从50变35
就是可以看出他真的是完全新开户的新手
但是
他在
就是
能够
如果他能够正确的一直按照开工事
执行下单的话
那他
就比较容易
就是他的资金就可以翻倍很高
那不过
其实
就是
就是他的进程力很高
可能是
会是因为
就是他的家族
就是那个不是他
他自己的总资金
就是
虽然那是他自己全部的钱
可是
可能
他的爸爸爷爷是有很多的钱
所以他
比较不怕赔掉那些钱
好反正就是
就是大家应该懂的意思
就是这个确实是他的
他自己
名下
控制的现金
虽然他是一个大学生
那
那所以他就比较容易有更高的精神力的下注尺度
所以大家也不用说
说觉得说啊为什么
好我好像没有办法按
好 反正就是大家也不用说什么啊为什么人家大学生就可以做到
做到这么高的
的精神力
但是你没有
就是
这个
毕竟
大家一开始
投胎之后就有一些先天的
优劣事嘛
那有些人可能先天就比较容易
下注精神力比较高一点
对
这个
就是
就是大家也不用觉得怎样啊反正
就是你也不能就直接冲来然后看下一抽会不会抽到比较有钱的
好
那
就是不同策略可以用不同的下注尺度
那如果当冲继续使用开一公式
然后
变成需要流畅的话
可以降低下注的尺度
好这边是说
说的是
就是
大家觉得
当冲
短线的当冲跟
长线的尺单
哪一个是会需要比较高的精神力
当然是当冲
比较不需要精神力嘛
因为你当天就把你的仓位出掉了
那
你的压力就没有那么大
你流长线单当然就是需要比较大的精神力
那当然
大部分人会觉得当冲你会开比较高的杠杆
那比较高杠杆的情况下当然会比较需要
比较大的精神力
但如果你下注的尺度
都是一样
例如说都是
1.5倍杠杆的话
那当冲你当然需要精神力会
比较低嘛
你如果长线尺单
1.5倍杠杆
可能你其实心里就已经很有压力
可能你只能承受
长线
1.2倍
甚至
就是1.1倍的杠杆
好
就是
像
我
如果在开比较
高的杠杆流仓的时候
就是我到现在
我睡觉的过程
我都还是会
梦到
就是股市可能
突然大涨或
大跌
就是
可能我持空单我就会梦到
然后股市突然大涨
然后
我记得有一次
我
就是
持多单
然后持比较多口的时候
然后我就
梦到
蔡英文在
那个选举车上的时候
肚子被射两颗子弹
然后股市又直接跌停
然后
我就直接输了2000多万这样
就是
这个还是
很容易会发生的嘛
因为其实
那个梦还是
会反映你在早上
尤其是睡觉之前想的事情
对
好
然后
就是大部分人会觉得说
当冲要
这个
心脏比较大
通常就是精神力要比较高
但其实不是啊
当冲需要精神力是明显低很多的
如果
你开的杠杆一样大
只是大部分人会默认
因为当冲需要精神力比较低
所以你本来就可以开比较大的杠杆
好那再来就是要讲
这个情绪关于制度
停止当天交易的
SOP
就是
我们应该在交易之前就先定好
情绪关于制度
他的SOP是怎样
然后如果有出现任何一项的话
你就应该停止
当日后续的所有交易
你应该要知道你一天输
多少钱之后你会until
然后你连续停损几单会until
然后
一天下单最多几次
会until
然后还有
只要你until一次
你就应该
完全的停止当天后续的交易
因为
因为你只要生气
你很可能后面
继续下单就都是在乱按
好
那这个也是
行为经济学就是
自律的方法
基本上就是两种
减少选择跟自我绑架
那例如说
你要这个
就是你要减肥好了
那
你就不要在
你看得到的地方
甚至在桌上摆放零食
那你只要
比较容易有
可以吃零食这个选择
你就比较有
可能会真的去吃零食
那
这个跟
这个传统经济学
当然不一样
传统经济学认为
这个你的桌上有没有摆零食
你都会
一样的选择要吃零食跟不吃零食
因为你要不要吃零食的时候
你就会画一个表格
然后
分析吃零食的优劣
之后
经过
慎重的计算
utility
吃零食的快乐跟
这个后来
这个变
变瘦的快乐
哪一个比较高
然后才
去决定吃那个零食
但是根本没有人会是这样决定的嘛
就是实际上
零食摆在桌上
也是比较容易
吃
所以呢
就是你要
减少你的选择
然后自我绑架的话
就是
可能你就是
跟你的同学室友讲说
如果你看到我喝珍珠奶茶
的话呢
这个
那
你就可以打我一拳
或者我就输你100块
或者说
那我就是小狗
那通常不要赌最后那个
因为其实没什么用
最后他就是
拿了珍珠奶茶
汪汪
那你就没什么用了
对吧
好
就是
这个是行为经济学里面
在任何事情上自律的方法
建立停止当日交易后的SOP
就是减少选择自我绑架
减少选择方法就是
关掉下单软体
起身离开房间
远离可以下单的电脑
那这样你就没有继续下单的选择
对吧
再来就是
自我绑架
就是找一个keeper
在发生需要停止当日交易的时候
跟他说
跟他说你要停止当日后续的所有交易
然后再来就是建立
习惯的后续行程
例如说
每一次
你不打单之后就出门去运动
或者去看电影
或者是
去
做家事
那
这个
如果看过一本书上的建议是
你就看书
但是呢
我觉得这是一个
非常没有用的建议
到底谁会在很生气的时候决定说
我总是在生气之后呢
就去看书
那
这个
好
但是这个书上
会建议你去看书嘛
对吧
好那再来就是
这边是要讲keeper嘛
就是守护者
也就是说呢
你应该要找
一个人当你的
风险控制者
就是风控
那
通常
在那个
基金啊
就是
那些基金可能是
几千万几亿以上
他们才会找一个人当你的风控
但是呢
如果是
你在台湾是一个说中产阶级
你可能有个
200万的总资产
那其实你就已经非常值得
拥有一个风控了
对吧
因为
你就算200万一次输个20万
其实也是蛮多钱的
那你找一个人
跟你互相当风险控制者
这个应该是蛮合理的
好那就是你可以随时
传讯息跟打电话给他
然后
他会接触你守护你的人
然后不要找
老公老婆
或者是男朋友女朋友
或者是家人
或者是
这个
异性当keeper
就是
例如说你找你老公
老婆当keeper
然后跟他说你今天输了100万
然后结果他就臭骂你一顿说
早就跟你说不要整天在那边
看股票
看股票在那边输钱
搞什么东西
你就很想把那100万赢回来
你就去
就去乱下单
那这样的话也不太好
就是
其实男女朋友还是
你们
虽然
假装钱都是分开的
但是
毕竟你们有潜在
会
那个
就是
财产共有的机会
然后所以
就是你们的利益
还是有互相有牵扯
最好是找一个
跟你完全没有任何利益牵扯的
比如说如果你是大学生
那你找你的大学室友就蛮不错的嘛
因为你比较不容易跟他结婚
然后
就是
当然
我们现在都
还是要正知正确
你还是有可能跟他结婚
但是
就是比较
机率比较低一点
然后
家人其实你跟他还是有一些
利益关系嘛
就算是兄弟姐妹
就是
当然感情比较好的兄弟
可能可以
但是
也有可能不行
因为
他有可能还是会影响到你
你有可能会影响到他
然后再来说是什么
什么学妹找
学长当keeper
那这个
就是如果你的
主要重点不是风险控制
是你希望发展你们的关系的话
那这当然是非常不错嘛
就是你们
这个会一起面对困难
然后
这个
好像在
之前的行为经济学课讲过
就是
共同冒险
是很容易让两个人爱上对方的一个方法
那但是呢
有可能
就是以赚钱来说的话
不一定是一个好的选择
好
那所以最好是找
这个
同性别的
可以理解金钱游戏的好朋友当keeper
好
这个
基本上
时间差不多
就是
就是赢家最大的命运就是很容易赢跟很难输钱
那
上一次
讲座好像是讲了这个
NSCI
跟付时调整日
来当
低风险高报酬教育机会
然后
配下半场一样讲情绪管理制度
那这一次我讲的是
这个
台风架策略配情绪管理制度
这样
好
就是
跟大家讲
我们要
怎么样玩这个游戏就是
你很容易赢钱
然后
很难输钱
这样
好刚好四点半
好谢谢大家
好我们就直接
直接
让大家可以举手发问QA好了
那这样的话这影片会比较
比较连续一点
好大家也不用
这个
不好意思发问
这样
那个好台风架制度
策略应该
应该大部分人还是
都听得懂嘛
应该
没有也
因为我也没有讲什么很复杂的
什么数学模型
应该大部分
大概大致上是知道
它的原理
然后
然后而且是可以执行的
好大家也不一定要问这个讲座的
我觉得可以问任何
任何
你想问的问题
这样
好
没有人要问问题吗
可以稍微讲一下那个台积电的策略吗
可以稍微讲一下那个台积电的事件交易策略吗
好
就是呢
基本上
事件交易策略
它有一个
主要的想法就是
在
某一些特定时间点的时候
股市很容易
突然大涨
或者是突然大跌
那而且那个时间点
如果它是可以预期的话
那你就可以
在
那个时间点
就是
上下挂
自动执行的出价单
如果它
往上喷就会自动追多单
如果往下跌就会自动追空单
也就是说
就是
基本上
大致上的想法就是这样
那例如说在
法说会
公布
的
法说会是下午嘛
那得下一个
那个
台积电是5点25分
夜盘会开盘
那在夜盘一开盘的时候
它开的价位可能大家会比较没有共识
像
前几天才有台积电法说会
它就是开在
就是一个很高的地方
然后在开完之后的
几分钟之后
它就暴跌了25块
不知道大家前几天有没有
看那个行情
那
这样的话你在做
追价的话
就是会
非常非常好
那也不只是台积电的这个时间
就是
很多很多的事情
在各式各样的商品上
都容易发生这样的事情
例如说
原油的库存公布
那就会影响原油的价格
类似像这样子
大家应该
可以理解吧
就是
我讲的是一个更general的概念
就是你可以在很多的商品上
都使用这样子的交易方法
好
还有人要问什么问题吗
看起来大家都
很害羞
好
因为我等一下就会
离开了
所以呢
等一下你们可能会问不到
就是你们可以先来问
这样子
那个台风策略嘛
那
OK我们这边在座
大概有
100人
那
假设说
我们这边每个人
大概打个五口选择权
或十口选择权
那加起来也许就是
1000口左右
那
如果说这个策略变成
它可以承受多大的吞吐量
然后不会被
淹过去
或者被提到之行之类的
就是
他
因为他
因为你不是只能够按价评的
就是
是所有的
所有的选择权都可以按
然后呢
这个策略其实也不会
只有你们知道
就是
他
蕴含的数学模型
都是
公开资讯嘛
然后汇放台风价这件事也是公开资讯
而且
事实上
涨上去的
就是他涨上去的口述
几乎都是被造势伤
也就是券商给吃下去的
就是
例如说
总共有
最上面
到最下面
我不确定总共会有多少个数字
可能有
好几十个不同的旅约价
然后
有put跟call
然后你要
把它全部都拉抬到
涨40%
的地方
那
那就是超级超级多的钱
就是
这个策略显然也不是只有
我知道嘛
就
就其实
我执行的大部分都是
就是
他们就是公开的资讯
然后所以
也不会只有我想到这样的策略
那
但是呢上涨过程还是
在
例如说在这一次可能是过了两分钟之后
才全部都涨到
就是突然
爆量涨上去
那那个爆量其实还是
造势商去吃下去的
那所以
基本上
就是不会有未纳量的问题
因为
然后他会在两分钟之后才涨上去
这个我也有
问过这个
就是期货商里面的人
就是
他们会有一个流程
就是说公布放台风架之后
他们会需要
这个稍微
电话确认然后很多个人查
很多个地方
都超级确定真的有放台风架了
他们才可以
一次把
因为他们按下去可能一次就是等于是按了
好几十亿或者
就是很多很多的部位才可以
把所有的旅约价
都买到上涨40%
因为他
例如说100买到140
那100到140之间全部的挂单都要吃下去
尤其是所有的旅约价
那他们一定不能出错嘛
所以他们有他们的
流程SOP
那
因为我们
可能
按的钱也没有很多
所以
就是我们不需要
他们这么冗长
过两分钟才打进去
那这两分钟我们可能就可以
就是可以
两分钟应该是
用手按一定是按得了嘛
也不需要程式交易的
对
然后但是因为他们
是绝对不能够承受
出错嘛
就是
因为他们说什么
什么
之前中华队
赢比赛的时候
然后网路上也有假消息说
什么第二天会放假
然后他们也赶快开会说
这个是不是要赶快来造势一下
难道中华队赢棒球
台湾第二天会放假吗
就是
他们还是要承受
虽然你听起来可能很荒谬
但是说不定也有人会
做一个假的图片说
明天要放假
开大家玩笑
结果其实明天没有要放假
就是
他们比较不能够承受这样
一次按错
然后就报案十几亿上去
好
就是
我大部分分享的策略啊
或者是像是什么
什么台积电啊
或者是
什么之前
航运啊
就是
都是那种微纳量超爆大
然后就算
分享出来
就是
至少啊我在
这几年
就是我跟
这么多的学生一起执行
一样的策略
都没有遇过
微纳量不够的问题
当然我也是会选择
因为我大部分都是做跟大盘有关的
或者是
跟世界经济有关的事情
那所以
就是
不太会遇到微纳量的问题
那如果你是
那种
很小的
单一个股流动性很差
那当然策略会有微纳量的问题
有关的问题
好
还有人要问什么问题吗
在哪一些管道可以再学习更多马克里洋老师的教训
这个是我的装脚是不是
他问我在哪里可以买到我的课程
他就是
反正你就密我的粉砖
然后
就是我
大概是有
目前大概
我忘记是多少
反正十几个策略
然后每一个
策略应该都会录成
可能一个半小时到两半小时
之间的
影片就是
很详细的把
大部分
大家可能会遇到的问题
我都有
就是
录在
那个
影片里面
那当然你看完之后看不懂
还是可以问我啦
不过
后续会问问题的比例
就是其实没有很高
因为我觉得我大部分都讲得很清楚
那像刚刚台湾架车会可能
我刚是用很简短的版本讲嘛
反正
大家可以
领略到他的那个
大概是怎样就可以
那
可能比较长的版本我就可以
讲更多什么后续调单的方式啊
或者是他为什么是涨到更好一倍
我刚有稍微讲一下
但
但其实
就是我尽量还是
每一个我都会想讲他的那个
背后的逻辑然后还有证明的过程
就是
希望大家
学东西
就是
是
你真的
就是
知道他那些数学都是
很有逻辑的
然后很正确的
而不是说
反正那个数学老师跟我说是这样
那应该就是这样
但是他不是我的装脚
就是一个
很像装脚的问题
问
哪里可以买到我的课
就是密我的粉砖这样
然后还有人有其他的问题吗
好啊
其实没有也没关系
那换阅阅讲
因为我们
差不多时间刚好四点半
那我们用乐乐的早晨谢谢马克洋
大家好
谢谢大家
好